am i dead
why does my eyes hurt we've never used
the rules of the Internet
yes it does exists it screams Jia's [ __ ]
someone actually wrote this [ __ ] rule
number one there are no girls on the
Internet
section true do not talk about B I'm not
gonna read the rest of it but there is
one rule in particular that is still
relevant
to this day I'm talking of course about
rule 34
there is porn of it no exceptions so
basically if I would say something
outrageous like Patera dactyls those
[ __ ] dinosaurs with the wings
okay let's search you know what why not
the pterodactyl porn
wait what the [ __ ] is this there's a
video
two million views that's oh my god oh my
god what the [ __ ] that was just a joke I
didn't think that would actually oh my
god no God
god damnit [ __ ] who would accept this
potato deck those men they used to be my
favorite dinosaur
needless to say don't flag this [ __ ]
video just because of this alright y'all
just flag every video even though I
sends rate the Joker this video was
supposed to be that I'm gonna search
something it's not gonna show up so
we're gonna make it now there is his
website that a friend friend told me
about this way I don't haven't heard of
it it's rule 34 so basically let's say
if I would show type PT PI here there
should technically oh my god what that's
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] god dammit why am
I always the bottom [ __ ] okay alright
god I can't all right I'm gonna come up
with something so crazy that's not gonna
be part of it we're gonna make it we're
gonna draw our own all right let's think
Snickers there's no [ __ ] way there is
Snickers porn oh my [ __ ] god oh my
god why Wow American snacks are huge I
love big American chocolate lamps a
nothing sexual about lamps oh my god oh
my god of course how they how did I not
see that what about a CD what about a
shopping cart ain't nothing sexual about
a shopping cart for [ __ ] sake
okay why don't we got to think deeper if
we're gonna beat this game we got to
think deeper now what possibly could not
be sexualized think with me help
goddamnit
help me goddamnit of course something
that is already sexual but come on come
on just beat you so now we're gonna make
her up okay alright so here we go
man it's hard to draw okay so we got a
but here have a net he has a nice suit
poppin home from work I'm drawing a
cleavage on a but this is great this the
butts have butts yeah yeah they they
must have butts okay well there you go
we filled an empty hole on the Internet
today you should all be proud
what about boobs oh my god we found a
loophole okay
look at that they love each other okay I
got it car ain't nothing sexual about
that homely [ __ ] [ __ ] I was wrong now
what didn't everything holy the [ __ ] is
this I want to die alright what about
this
continents what the [ __ ] don't turn
Sweden into a penis and a snake is that
snail god damn it ah this can never be
unseen Sweden
okay what's sexual about Sweden what and
then jesus [ __ ] christ is wrong with
you guys what about a toilet please
Scott don't ruin toilets for me oh my
[ __ ] god that is [ __ ] up alright oh
my god I'm not even gonna show that
because you're not gonna be hot you're
not gonna be a happier person what about
an iPad what [ __ ] why would you do that
why the pony stuff it's so [ __ ] weird
what about math
are you [ __ ] kidding me
guide to making rule 34 take a character
likely underage from the 1980s Jesus
Christ remove clothing stephanie spit in
God's eye well I couldn't have put it a
better way myself what about a video
game console there's the DES in the
background - who the [ __ ] had to
Dreamcast's those [ __ ] were so expensive
what about rule 34 itself oh my [ __ ]
god people are [ __ ] insane oh my god
I can't do this [ __ ] anymore
I can't do this anymore I'm done
y'all sick you're all sick now excuse me
I'm going to bleach my eyes I'm blind
okay gross whatever you do don't flag
this video it will all have been for
nothing if you do number two
I've forgotten number three like this
video subscribe for more quality content
like this and join me on my path to
madness as always brofist